وعند الحديث عن تغلغل الاخوان الشرق
اوروبا فلابد من الحديث عن البوسنه التي
بدا الاعلام الغربي بوصفها كخزان للتطرف
بتنام نفوس تيار الاخوان فيها الشبكات
القريبه من جماعه الاخوان برزت في البوسنه
منذ اوائل التسعينات التزامن مع انشاء عدد
من المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي تدير
الخدمات الانسانيه لكنها في بعض الاحيان
قدمت الدعم للمسلحين المشاركين في صراع
البوسنه في ذلك الوقت تحت الستار العمل
الانساني تقرير مركز توثيق الاسلام
السياسي في النمسا قال ان معظم الاخوان
الذين نشطوا في البوسنه وحتى المناطق
المجاوره لها خلال الحرب تركوا البلاد بعد
انتهاء الصراع مع ذلك وجد التنظيم العالمي
للاخوان حلفاء في شخصيات محليه بارزه في
البوسنه مثل الرئيس السابق ايشاء
والمفتيين السابقين والحالي ايضا للبلاد
المجلس الاوروبي للفتوى المرتبط بالاخوان
بدا ايضا بتقديم دورات في سرايفو في عامي
حضر بعضها مفتي الاخوان يوسف القرضاوي
انذاك منظمه اخرى عضو في اتحاد المنظمات
الاسلاميه في اوروبا شكلت مظله الاخوان في
القاره ايضا وهي جمعيه الثقافه والتعليم
والرياضه في البوسنه رغم هذه هذا التمدد
والاتصالات رفيعه المستوى التنظيم الى ان
الوجود لاخواني في البوسنه يمكن وصفه
بالصغير نسبيا في الحجم والتاثير وفق مركز
الاسلام السياسي بالنمسا ايضا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات